les prestations masculin est attribué à
roy keane can 2017 joaquin phoenix
remporte le prix d'interprétation
masculine
almodovar l'a dit tout le monde l'a
compris sow joaquin phoenix le costard
est impec les chaussures un peu moins
mathieu la barbe et les lunettes noires
en moins on a cru revoir la dégaine de
celui qui il y a neuf ans disait vouloir
tout plaquer pour se reconvertir dans le
hip hop
en deux ans il a joué aux mecs
à moitié bourré qui se croient rappeur
alors qui sait très bien qu'il est qu'il
est mauvais ça aurait pu marquer à ce
moment là la fin de sa carrière il a eu
du bol de rebondir quand même
woody allen spike jones paul thomas
anderson et enfin lynne ramsay depuis
son coup de calgon joaquin phoenix est
revenu en grâce mais toujours entre
ombre et lumière tout en contraste entre
un métier d'acteur qu'il a fait sien et
un plaisir de jouer plus qu'incertain
des rôles de petites frappes aux
personnages plus taiseux joaquin phoenix
est peu à peu épaissie l'occasion de se
durcir le cuir pour celui qui a grandi
dans une ombre celle d'un grand frère
star mort en pleine gloire
physique qui le complexe une carrière
qui le laisse perplexe retour sur le
démon de joaquin phoenix
[Musique]
beautiful day de lynne ramsay c'est le
joaquin phoenix movie traduction celui
qui cochent toutes les cases d'un film
avec joaquin phoenix
tout y est performances physiques
personnage neurasthénie pouvoir quasi
mutique succès du week end entre taxi
driver et la nuit du chasseur phoenix m
massif animal et incarne le fantasme
d'une réalisatrice qui voit en lui son
tenir au mieux
il faut juste dire tu nous fais trop
beau joaquin phoenix ne l'a jamais été
sa beauté singulière contrarié voire
complexé et ça depuis son premier grand
rocher duzan ne semble pas prête à tout
ambiance jeune premier gilles dubois
léger les gaules et comme une ablette il
est aussi épais qu'une planche apports
et etc c'est un peu quelque part ça
documente aussi ce qu'était joie qu'un
phoenix à l'époque c'est à dire un jeune
homme pas bien dans son corps avec en
plus un bec de lièvre qui a été voilà
qui a laissé cette cette cicatrice sur
sur sa bouche donc un gamin extrêmement
complexé génie que c'est un peu
l'histoire du vilain petit canard celui
d'une fratrie qui grandit dans une secte
et chez les hippies ambiance nature et
découvertes ses frères et soeurs
s'appelle river summer liberty règne et
puis lui
joaquin premier complexe oui une époque
il avait même carrément changer son
prénom puisque il émit cfrp leaf ou
feuilles en français parce qu'il voulait
un prénom nature comme son frère sa
grande soeur et donc pendant pendant
très longtemps il s'est fait happer leaf
au début de sa carrière
phoenix est précoce il débute à 8 ans
dans des séries pour vieille dame comme
arabesque ou et en vf c'est extra ça tu
nous emmènes le voir s'il te plaît
m'attendre
non river son frère lui joue pour bob
renner dans stand by me autre ambiance
car l'instar de la famille se river
belle gueule belle mèche à astugue
rivers et l'acteur solaire celui qui
éclipsent son cadet river phoenix était
quand même faut se souvenir qu'à
l'époque c'était l'équivalent d'un
nouveau james dean dire qu'il a vraiment
marqué son époque et pour joaquin
phoenix son grand frère s'était pas rien
mais voilà un soir d'octobre 93 devant
le viper room la boîte de johnny depp
river fait une overdose puis meurt dans
les bras de son frère pour joaquin
l'ombre de rivers planera toujours même
si à partir de là hollywood lui tend les
bras
[Musique]
tai chi fargo les rôles vont s'enchaîner
chez oliver stone ridley scott james
mangold et le triomphe de walk the line
[Musique]
marqué par la vie phoenix joue depuis
vingt ans des personnages d'écorcher
[Musique]
il sera son rôle dans two lovers c'est
la référence du genre mais aussi
l'archétype de ce que des réalisateurs
pendant tout ce temps viendront chercher
chez lui
ça vaut pour james gray ou dans un autre
genre woody allen
c'est bien ou c'est mal en fait c'est
surtout risqué car joaquin phoenix
l'actor studio puissance 10 le mec qui
met ses tripes sur la table pour solde
de tout compte
illustration alors qu'il tourne dans une
école pour walk the line de james
mangold demande juste à l'acteur de
casser sa guitare laveur s'exécute mais
pour phoenix et ben c'est un peu light
une seule prise une inondation en prime
c'est la touche joaquin phoenix ya
toujours ce risque d'en faire des
caisses et en même temps c'est je pense
que c'est pour ça aussi qui choisit de
manière très intelligemment ses rôles
etc cinéaste sait qu'il est toujours
très bien des filières en général très
bien dirigés quand ce chéchia manager
james gray chez lynne ramsay placer des
cinéastes qui savent ce qu'ils peuvent
tirer lui et donc ils savent aussi qu'il
faut le retenir mais voilà un phénix
n'est pas du genre à se regarder c'est
même l'un verbe jusqu'à heures l'acteur
refuse de voir un seul de ses films
phoenix trouve qu'il joue mal qu'il joue
à côté de la plaque reçoit motorisation
hybride résultats longtemps phoenix aura
joué les héros usées et avec eux la
fatigue d'un acteur dont la carrière
culmine et qui ne sait pas vraiment
pourquoi
de rôle d'acteur fatigué phoenix lors a
incarné pendant deux ans de performances
non-stop un canular contre hollywood
contre lui même et un public qui n'a pas
tout compris
hollywood a horreur de ça horreur qu'on
lui renvoie justement le reflet
grotesque de ce qu'est hollywood de
scale star system de ce que sont les
médias même letterman qui connaît depuis
longtemps c'est pas trop sur quel pied
danser et limites il ridiculise mais
sans trop le savoir donc voilà sans trop
le savoir on a peut-être aussi vu tous
les films de phoenix en oubliant que
derrière ces rôles d'écorché vif tu se
cachait peut-être un très grand acteur
comique
ce sont nos jobs phoenix lui a donc
décidé de continuer à jouer à creuser et
à suivre sa ligne
[Musique]
temps